[Music]
what do you guys think
of social nudity
social news like if i go to a nude beach
like yeah like nature is traveling
yeah i'm in place time and place what
does that mean i wish the
for me i wish the laws were you could be
naked 100
anytime anywhere me too that's pretty
cool yeah maybe
like sexual harassment and stuff or
decline because it's like
not so you're not so um deprived or
whatever
as a man for like female bodies and then
you'll get to desensitize and be like oh
it's all nature
i don't know about that i just feel like
sometimes
i don't want to go to the room to put on
pants i'd rather walk outside
because i got to grab the trash and
bring it back and then
i'm like why do i have to
put on pants right true and then
some people would even say put on some
shoes
some yeah true i don't know
about you i think if there are
designated areas where
they're just like yeah for like this
whole entire like perimeter or whatever
like be naked do whatever you want or
don't do whatever like who cares you
know
but i do think that there are a lot of
people
for maybe like religious reasons that
don't want to see
your bare body um muslims foreign
and so you can actually get into trouble
like um
like you know when you like have like a
job and they make you attend all these
like sexual
um harassment harassment like lessons or
whatever
um yeah i learned that you don't even
have to be harassing someone for it to
be considered like sexual harassment but
if you send
someone that doesn't want your dick pic
like if you send them a dick pic
they can report you even though they
haven't like physically touched you
even if they haven't ever said anything
i think in new york if you send and
solicit a dick pic
you could get fine because it's
violating their eyes right well yeah no
dick is pretty so i get it i heard i had
a pretty one
girl i'm sure from your doctor
or like from his mom
your dick is very pretty joseph yeah
but yeah cause i was thinking like if if
okay if i came out to take out the trash
and i'm like what's up bob
how's it going and i went back in
they're probably saying man this dick
it's kind of cool yeah it's kind of cool
but yeah let's say
bob but like let's say bob comes out and
then he did it
and it's like oh bob you got to put
something on bro like
man your guts hanging out like come on
man
you know maybe it's it's different like
maybe
depending on if you were if you got a
nice body or not
okay so that's how it works in your
world social nudity is only
uh available as an option for people to
have
a nice physique put some put some
clothes on you ugly [ __ ]
but that's through your eyes there are a
lot of people that prefer
like larger heavier set overweight
people
chubby chasers oh that's true so i gotta
move into a neighborhood
where they think i'm hot because if i'm
in the wrong neighborhood oh you're
gonna be honest i have to cover up
or you have to go in the neighborhood
where you think they're hot too so maybe
you're just
meeting all your new neighbors bro it'll
be an orgy block party
oh if everyone thinks they're hot that
might be a good thing then you'll
actually love your neighbor literally
literally
yeah that's pretty good love thy
neighbor i can't wait till you become a
[ __ ] multi-billionaire dude
i can't wait why because the [ __ ] that's
good you're gonna make it happen
i'm not gonna [ __ ] my neighbors i didn't
say that dude but i will have a whole
block and
and and maybe wait hold on so okay
so because you have expressed your like
one of your dreams is for all of us to
live
in like a cold desert i don't want you
to be my neighbor that's where i was
gonna ask i'm like wait hold on
are these dreams like happening tonight
yeah but i'll have neighborhoods
like it'll be like the truman show where
like this will be my [ __ ] party block
this is my family friend's block where
do you live
everywhere like um [ __ ] monday
tuesday with you guys right
wednesday thursday thursday with someone
else
friday saturday with the [ __ ] party the
[ __ ] party
yeah what if we want to
join the [ __ ] party don't oh [ __ ]
that's his old [ __ ] party yeah
disgusting
rejected guys we got we got or can we be
invited when you're spending time with
our families
and we we get to go to your [ __ ] oh we
get to swap
i don't want to [ __ ] people joe's bucks
why true true
oh it's like sharing sex toys again yeah
it's like sharing a toothbrush dude
not down well they're human beings okay
and treat them like humans
say that the unattractive ones shouldn't
be naked so
yeah thank you thank you so what's going
on in that brain of yours
well they're human they're just ugly
okay
okay okay so it's different so by saying
by treating them differently is treating
them like
humans huh because you said treat
everyone like humans like everything no
no no
no i'm saying everyone my [ __ ] buddies
yeah
have hearts they have feelings they've
been good to me
and you need to be good to them too but
all the other ones they're just
i don't know who they are okay
all right well this took a sexual turn
but uh
for nick and lynn's speaking of sexual
no just kidding
yeah we already did that one uh so for
nick and lin's who run
a uh blog site called naked wanderings
they are
uh naturists nudists yeah and that's the
word nudists some of my nature's uh
their nudists from belgium and they run
a blog channel or blog website
called naked wanderings and they
i don't know in europe somewhere and
waffles outside i know
beautiful waffles germany and they want
to be naked all the time eating waffles
apparently they're probably hot not a
bad lifestyle true
uh so their whole mission is to spread
the word of
nudism naturism whatever you want to
call it because they see it as a dying
lifestyle i don't know it's a lifestyle
yeah i didn't know his lifestyle being
able to just colonies
yeah people go to beaches and like have
parties and stuff
and like they they get together with
their nudist friends and just they're
just
naked no sex involved there's just
platonic
like they're just you know drinking wine
talking about families and everything
yeah
i mean even kids are part of these
families it seems really freeing that
makes me
feel uncomfortable that's that makes you
uncomfortable
but not orgies no i don't want to see
them naked
but i want to be naked ah gotcha you're
the only person
that can be naked yeah and that doesn't
make you uncomfortable it makes complete
sense to me
this is joe logic it makes sense why
you want to see their ugly ass bodies
that makes me uncomfortable
well i just it's just funny to me that
you want to be the only person it's
because you're sexualizing
everything here and you imagine everyone
to be so
hot and so nice body i'm kidding
i'm picturing family members naked and
i'm like that's disgusting
i don't want to see [ __ ] adults and
kids and grandparents
butt ass naked all over me part of
japanese culture is to
in the bath yeah bathe yeah but i don't
make it but i'm uncomfortable
seeing them well i think you miss
misheard or i miss said what i wanted to
point out and i
just wanted to point out that you're not
bothered that everyone else is fully
clothed yeah and you're the only one
that's naked which is
so [ __ ] weird if they don't look at
me weird that's fine
they're for sure you're the only one no
but if this is normal like if it's like
we're chilling right
like and it's like every i can be i
think it's fine
okay like if they accept me for being a
nudist right
and everyone's chill with it i'd rather
see everybody else insecurities man
huh you can't have insecurities all i'm
saying is if i had the option
i would rather not everyone else be
naked i want to see them in clothes
yeah cover up be decent when we went to
yosemite
when it was me gio and taika and we were
hiking we found this really cool
creek and it got like deeper and deeper
and deeper into the forest
and you know like yosemite like the
trees are really really dense so we got
to a place
where it was just ourselves and we're
like
oh [ __ ] maybe we could be naked here and
so i got naked she got naked and tucker
got naked and we're just hanging out
like on the beach at the creek it was
awesome it was really cool
is that when you dug a hole and you
[ __ ] laid in it
that was hawaii what would i do why uh
dug a hole when you were naked
wait no not naked no that was it yeah i
was naked what what was i doing how did
i dig
didn't you make an instagram post of you
like make it on a
like a lake bed or some [ __ ] yeah i did
yes that was him that was in yosemite
that was the place yes there forgot
i was cracking up that's why i was like
oh my god would you guys ever want to go
to a nudist beach or like a nudist
camping so there's nudist camping as
well where you literally
pitch a tent and then you're no i don't
want to do that yeah for me like i like
being the whole i like the whole nudist
i guess lifestyle i think that's really
cool
but like mindy was saying i also don't
want to offend anyone
else if that's not what they're about oh
but
in this case though it you're going to a
place where it is everyone's down yeah
i think that's super cool everyone goes
there everyone has a great time that's
awesome
these beautiful people this is a naked
lens they're they're the
oh i like how we place the baguette oh
yeah it's like perfectly placed i love
it
yeah make it bigger please oh yeah how
do i make it bigger command plus command
plus oh i wouldn't mind seeing them
naked
man nice because they're hot you're
finding no
they're just they're not ugly they're
not ugly they're they're good-looking
people
change and then this is like them
hanging out with their friends on a
nudist oh that's so cool
maybe the guy on the left not so much
but yeah this guy or no no that guy yeah
you're like take him out but yeah
everyone else is kind of cool yeah
what's wrong with that guy
he looks like a liquor store owner
what's wrong with liquor stores
i
i just picture him behind a register
but you look like you're from a biology
book from the 80s i'm not talking about
me i'm talking about them this is his
fantasy
gotcha yeah no it's not a fantasy
they're not it's not sexualized i'm just
saying like
it's it's uh yeah just keep going
yeah i don't know like after reading
this article and like reading about
their lifestyle it made me curious and
like made me
like i'm like hey tiff do you want to
try
like i guess once quarantine's over or
whatever log down
and all this stuff is uh done with would
you be interested
in going to a nudist beach or a nudist
camping trip
with me uh sure yeah you guys don't
strike me as nudist people
oh for sure not you don't even do
nudists in your own home
we don't but but what makes you want to
do it but it's good
so the reason why i say yes is because
i'm the adventurous like try everything
one kind of person
yeah that's why i see that's the only
reason why
no other reason other than that yeah and
i think i think i've adopted that
mentality too so i'm like i'm kind of
like down
at least try at least once and see if i
am
going to get embarrassed or whether i'm
not or you know it was actually hard for
me to
get comfortable at the korean spot like
i we saw when we all went we were just
naked near each other i was like
is it because all your friends are
around you so it's like it's weird being
naked with your friends
um honestly
i think the stranger part was more weird
for me
oh since naked strangers yeah i think
i don't know they're pretty ugly huh
yeah yeah that's true
i would want to do a full nude
experience like full nude
camping experience where it's not just
sitting on the beach yeah but
uh you're rock climbing naked and
there's a line and everyone's climbing
up and watching
the the view looking up is going to be
quick you want to do
all the sports where your ass cheeks do
have something
naked mountain biking naked i'm pulling
suit out can you imagine
[Laughter]
you're like benching hey can you spot me
not you don't let me get it
i want i wanna i wanna be sedentary not
just dripping on your head i'm gonna be
naked and moving
that's what i want maybe we've got to
pick sports that are different oh can
you imagine
oh geez i heard that athenians used to
work out naked
see and then they did the olympics news
yeah oh yeah they did olympics
yeah because they didn't they didn't
watch yeah they didn't want [ __ ] to
bother them
and then like to see the muscles
activate and all that as a whole they're
like yeah
that's that's cool liking the beauty of
the humans stop until you get someone
with the stank ass
what's stink ass literally that you
can't smell it through the camera i'm
just saying if you're wrestling what
what camera
we're you're on new to speech yeah oh i
picture that you're post someone's
posting it on stories and you're like oh
this guy's so stupid you added that
whole thing that's quite a bit of a jump
there
i was thinking like back then yes me too
we were all with each other here she's
like
what camera you know the greek camera
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos
and i know it's been a million years in
the making but we
finally got just kidding news merch
yep so make sure you go down to the
store below and you can run around
yeah you can get a piece of jk news and
thank you guys for supporting
thank you bye-bye
you